hey there I'm going to show you how to
create this Mayfair witch's inspired
title card in After Effects let's get
started
[Music]
my name is Cameron and before we get
started today I want to invite you to
watch my complimentary Workshop over at
motionscience.tv Workshop where I'll
show you seven of my cinematic tips and
tricks in motion Design This is a free
30-minute Workshop visit
motionscience.tv Workshop after watching
this video you will not regret it have
you seen the title sequence for Mayfair
Witches by elastic if not go check it
out it's amazing this title sequence
inspired me to recreate a scene so let's
talk about how to make it in After
Effects to start off we will search for
an interesting background image after
finding one online and importing it into
After Effects we will position and scale
the background image until we settle on
an interesting frame next we will add
the CC toner effect to give the image a
blue and green look we do this by
adjusting the highlights and the
mid-tones then we will click right here
to make the layer 3D the next step is
add a 3D camera I tend to mostly use
OneNote cameras because of ease of use
with the camera selected we will add two
keyframes to give the camera Movement we
want a simple camera move where we push
into the frame now we need to make our
background image look more distressed so
we search for a cracked paint texture
online once imported into After Effects
we take the 3D box position and scale
the image to our liking and change the
mode to multiply so that the cracked
paint texture blends with the background
image we will also add a black and white
effect to remove any color from the
image and add a levels effect to the
levels effect we will adjust the black
and gray value sliders to make the paint
cracks have a stronger presence in the
composite the composite needs more
florals at this point so we will do a
quick search for those download and
Import in After Effects take the 3D box
create a quick mask to isolate the
flowers position and scale the flower
image using the rule thirds change the
mode to multiply and again add the black
and white effect to remove any color and
add the levels effect to make the floral
arrangement darker in the composite to
give the composite more movement we can
add an animated cracking effect we go to
action VFX and download an overhead
graph round crack 3D render we import
this in After Effects tick the 3D box
position rotate and scale the renderer
change the mode to hard light and again
we add the black and white and levels
effects same principles as before we
need to add some picture frames to the
composite so we search these out online
download them and import them into
Photoshop in Photoshop we remove the
white background so the picture frames
have transparency or Alpha channels
within them we import the Photoshop
files into after effects and we drag
each image onto the composition icon in
the project window to create individual
picture frame pre-comps right now the
picture frames look quite different from
each other and we want them to look
similar in color so to do this we use CC
toner on one picture frame and Sample
the highlights and mid-tones of the
other picture frame now we have similar
color tones between the two picture
frames and they look great over in mid
Journey we generate two vintage witch
portraits and import them into after
effects as well each portrait and image
is brought into a picture frame pre-comp
and placed under the picture frame then
using the mask tool we remove The
Unwanted edges of the witch portrait
images back in the main composition we
position and scale the two picture
frames using the rule of thirds so that
they sit nicely in the comp we tick the
3D box for each picture frame and tick
cast shadows in the material options the
picture frames are also positioned about
30 pixels forward in Z space to separate
them from the background layers next we
add a point light and adjust the shadow
darkness and diffusion with the point
light in the comp we will position it
close to the elements in Z space so that
it only illuminates a small section of
the comp and creates Intrigue within
animate the position of the point with
two keyframes the point light will start
left and then move right we need a
little more light in the scene to
brighten things up so we will add an
ambient light with an intensity of 30
percent next we duplicate the picture
frames we set the duplicate layer modes
to screen and turn off cast Shadows for
these duplicate layers with then draw a
mask with a high feather amount on the
right side of the lower picture frame
and on the bottom edge of the upper
picture frame we then animate these
masks to simulate specular light being
illuminated from the moving point light
we will add a quick name super we'll
tick the 3D checkbox and position the
name super slightly forward in Z space
we tick cast shadows and tent the type
so that it isn't pure white but instead
matches the white values of the comp we
also add a fast box blur with a very low
value to slightly soften the type to
finish the scene we can do one of two
things we can add a black solid layer to
the top of the layer stack draw a mask
invert the mask and input a high feather
value to create a nice vignette or we
can go a completely different route and
turn off the vignette layer add a new
adjustment layer to the top layer stack
and to this layer apply one of my
favorite plugins from Boris FX Sapphire
called film effect and there you have it
that's how I would recreate a scene from
the Mayfair witch's title sequence if
you enjoy the video please hit that like
button and consider subscribing to my
YouTube channel for more content just
like this I would love to hear your
thoughts of the video so please leave a
comment or question below as always
thank you for watching and I look
forward to connecting with you in my
next video
[Music]
thank you